so the DMT is like a doorman who is like  here here's life here's death I'm gonna  open this up and kind of usher you  through you and you give him a tip I  just think it's arrogant to reduce  everything that happens at the moment of  death 21 chemical equation the fact is  we just don't know yet we offer an  excellent internship program  you don't think I'd fit in here  look at me you bet overlay use in messy  close-range situations how do they feel  yeah good now do your very best  impersonation of a German aristocrats  formal greeting no eggsy human behavior  is very predictable I touch you here I  steal from here I tap you here I steal  from here I step to here you're not  gonna slap my face are you why you would  if you knew where my hand was  okay are you get it are you get it you  get their focus